hello thank you for joining us today for
the second webinar in our machine
learning series image processing with
deep neural Nets we are very pleased to
welcome today's presenters
Marcus van Ulm SiC and Giulio Allison
dharini
who are both members of our image
processing research and development team
Marcus is going to give us an overview
of applying neural network concepts to
image processing and Giulio will present
on real-world computer vision
applications my name is Cassidy Hinkle
project manager with Wolfram research I
will be your online host for this
machine learning webinar series I am
joined by several of my will from
colleagues behind the scenes to respond
to your typed questions during the event
and help point you to the resources you
need feel free to submit your questions
using the control panel on the right
side of your screen you can resize the
windows to customize your webinar
experience we have had good success with
Firefox and Chrome browsers so if you
experience any issues with the screen or
audio streaming you might want to try
logging in with a different browser
today's webinar is a great opportunity
for you to learn more about deep
learning approaches to image processing
the presentation notebooks and a
recording of today's session will be
sent to you in a few days so you can
continue to build on your understanding
and work with the examples before
passing the microphone to Marcus I'm
going to share our first poll question
asking you about your interest in
today's webinar topics are you
interested in deep learning frameworks
in the area of image processing or in
both of these areas if you don't have a
strong interest in either area you can
indicate that as well when the poll
question appears on your screen please
select your response and we'll share the
answers after everyone has had a chance
to respond all right thank you for your
responses I see a big majority are
interested in both of these areas which
is great as we will give a great
understanding of both of these concepts
throughout today's event
so let's go ahead and do one more poll
question as a follow-up for those that
already have some experience with neural
net frameworks this poll question is
going to ask which frameworks you have
used please mark all that apply or it's
okay to just skip this poll if it
doesn't apply to you so so Marcus it
looks like majority of the people that
have used the frameworks are using
tensorflow
and I hope it's going to be my job today
to convince them that there are other
frameworks out there just as Mathematica
and our built-in deep neural network
framework that is built on MX net by the
way for those who don't know good
evening I'd like to welcome you all to
the first part of today's webinar titled
image processing with deep neural nets
and it's my pleasure with a slight
German accent to give you the overview
and some insights so basically the look
into the tool chest of our framework and
give you an introduction on how to
utilize all the tools that you find in
there so it's a little bit the
nitty-gritty part the tedious part and
then my colleague with his Italian charm
will show you the scope of what we can
do in Mathematica with these tools and
he is going to have the pleasure to show
really really nice fancy examples okay
so time is limited and no further ado
let me get started this is a quick rough
outline of the first part first I will
just say a few general words it's titled
prelude about image processing and
neural networks which have a very
intimate relationship then in order to
basically look into the tool chest
I'll build with you an image classifier
from step one all the way through step
by step to show you what is needed what
these are different tools are for and
how to improve you classify as you go
along and then once we have a class of
we'll analyze these networks not
necessary the one that we built but also
other ones and see what they can do what
they can't do what the properties are
and then it's it's first simple
but straightforward application example
I'll show you how to build a image
retrieval system with such a classifier
all right so a quick general concept
image processing is done on a daily
basis unfortunately subconsciously in
the back of our brain about one third of
our brain does it on a daily basis
without being aware of it the brain
doing it with 86 billion neurons 5.8
million kilometres of fibers wiring that
is 200 trillion synapses or connections
or parameters that you can learn and all
of that is done on a bio where you may
say of doing roughly one petaflop so
even more and most amazingly all of that
just was a energy consumption of 20
watts we don't have that luxury with our
hardware yet I working with an external
GPU but things are going in a great
direction and just to show you the
difference between what image processing
was just six seven years ago prior to
2012 somewhat the start date the year
zero for image processing and your
networks due to the Hinton paper and his
wooden of the image net challenge
quickly show you what it was before hand
before hand image processing was to do
like image transformation on the spatial
domain doing filtering like finding
corners in an image doing a shape
analysis with morphological operations
like here finding the spots of a cheetah
then Holy Grail which still have
somewhat the holy grail of image
processing is doing two segmentation
there were all kinds of classical
approaches how to find certain segments
like your heart chambers
then there was registration
[Music]
showing basically hopes this can go down
here showing basically if your two
images how to make them congruent how to
basically compare data measurements in
one image with data measurements in the
other image and then there's a lot of
recognition tasks that we're already
going into the area of machine learning
like OCR optical character recognition
like what we have here under text
recognized in Mathematica this already
included some machine learning and
neural network networks being part of
machine learning but when I now say
machine learning has somewhat set it
apart from the classical machine or any
prior to the successes especially the
success that we had in the year 2012
when Geoffrey Hinton and his team won
their image net challenge and since then
it's possible to do things like this you
present an image and with a command like
we have here with image identify the
system can load a neural network and
then actually tell what's in this image
something that was unthinkable 10 years
ago so it's a quite remarkable
development or you can do really funky
things like let's say I have here the
image of a horse and then there are
networks out there which I will
introduce to you in a minute like this
network that can transform horses into
zebras is this a train network it has
been trained and lots of zebra and horse
images and so it can basically convert
horses into zebras and this is how it
would look like so this is say image up
there and kaboom I suddenly have zebra
I'm there
well more African grass berries and
European grass or green American grass
they see it not just the horse changes
but the background just change little
too and then we have even features that
you also would encounter in real living
neural networks for example you can
somewhat mimic the concept of dreaming
basically boosting the activity of
certain neurons in your neural network
and thus dreaming up certain aspects of
what's stored in the numeral network and
I won't go through all of the codes by
the way there is some code popping up in
this talk I'm not going through this
code step-by-step this is more for those
who want to download this notebook later
on and do some experiments so what this
is doing is basically it's a network
that okay I try to scroll that takes in
an image like what you have seen here
and then it tries to maximize the
activity of a certain neural layer and
always-changing then in by a
backpropagation which I explain in a
minute the incoming image and thereby
projecting what's stored in that layer
on that image and if I'm lucky I can
scroll all the way down here and this
would be then such an image you can see
that the force is almost gone and has
been populated with all kinds of exotic
animals birds in this case and these are
features like feathers and so forth that
are stored as features in a certain
layer of your neural network that's in
this case inception Network version 1
and that's been being projected back
onto this image and we'll go into this
shortly after actually one should not
call it deep dream but rather a deep
nightmare because most of these images
as they come up look rather well spooky
at least all right so that's roughly
they've the scope of what I will talk
about this morning or afternoon or
evening wherever you are and I'll pick
up pretty much exactly where Sebastian
three weeks ago
left off introducing the framework and
the technicalities of the world from
language implementation of a deep neural
network framework he had basically
presented the Linette model the
classical model by Jung McCune from 1998
that's capable of reading and written
digits and we do have such a model built
into Mathematica you can call these
things up by net model we also have a
whole repository that we'll visit in a
sec
and when you load this network up you
can just look at it you see it's just a
chain of your layers are going from
input to convolution layer pooling layer
and so forth and once that's loaded you
can directly apply it to your data and
in this case you'll get even or correct
398 for all the digits being read in
okay so far so good I won't repeat this
what I will repeat though is I will take
this network and try to cope with a
different data set and see what I need
to improve in order to get better
results and what I will now okay
initially all right the data set in
question is a cypher data set sigh far
ten cipher by the way stays for the
Canadian stands for the Canadian
Institute of Advanced Research located
in Toronto ten stands for the fact that
these are 60,000 small images that
belong to ten classes ten classes of
different type like planes ships cats
dogs and so forth and you don't have to
go hunting for these data sets on the
web all of this is built into
Mathematica into the resource framework
that we have and that you can then
utilize to directly load these things
into your system okay so this is just a
sample of six of these images you see
they're rather small just 32 times 32
pixels but if you enlarge them you can
somewhat see okay this is a fire truck
so it classifies as a truck and these
are all the different categories
airplane or a mobile bird and so forth
so that's the data set I'd like now to
apply the Linette network on and the
first issue that I have is that the
network has an encoder and a decoder
which unfortunately always ends up at
the bottom of this implementation yeah
of the chain and that as an option you
specify the encoder that takes an object
whatever it is the sound file an image
some data a plane data or whatever there
is going to be and convert that into an
array of yeah
neural excitations you may call it if
you would like to interpret that way and
the net encoder basically takes here an
image of size 32 times 32 and subtracts
kind of a mean image of a mean value of
0.5 essentially making sure that you
don't always have excitatory behavior in
all of the image but that dark regions
basically are F negative values and
thereby inhibit the network so that's
our encoder here and that's the decoder
the decoder is basically a decoder that
takes a vector of class probabilities
which will get and converts them into
labels of that particular class so up
here you can see what's going on the
encoder the right define here s encode
takes an image like here a little plane
and converts that into a large array of
three times 32 times 32 values so total
of twenty four thousand seven hundred
four values and the decoder that's the
opposite it takes an array in this case
just a vector of ten digits and converts
that into a label so you're the first
instant basically is a category of
airplanes so I get to label airplane and
so that's already now what I need to do
spray it forward in order to convert
this to a net that can handle cypher
data then the net okay this is a network
so this is the encoder decoder
now let's quickly analyze this network
for example I can call up net
information and ask for how many learn
about parameters are there in this
network and it's quite impressive that
basically what you do when you learn and
network you do fitting and that you have
to fit here
657 well 650,000 parameters roughly if I
don't fit them yet if I haven't learned
them I have to initialize and network to
just provide random values and if that's
so I can already plug in an image but I
probably get it wrong classification a
classification saying horse or plane
it's essentially random
all right so we know how to set up a
network now I have to to the next slide
next slide over yeah that's next slide
ok this next slide and now I'd like to
quickly before I run and train this
network quickly analyze what steps and
what layers we'll use here and why we
use them what Lynnette is called the net
new network is called a convolutional
net work because the prominent layers in
this network are so-called convolutional
layers in contrast to linear layers of
fully connected layers
it's called linear layers in Mathematica
and difference is as follows if I have
basically a layer I have here an array
of neurons or activities and the
question is now how do they connect to
the next layer if you have a linear
layer a fully connected layer
essentially then every neuron or every
value gets transmitted to the next to
every value of next layer so essentially
if you let say have an input online
values coming in and seven values going
out essentially have you seven times
it's nine values waits to learn plus
biases for all the neurons appear so
another seven so a total of 70
parameters it's a such a fully connected
network would imply and if for example
now the very first layer the
convolutional network layer in my
example up there would have been a fully
connected layer basically taking 32
times 32 pixel values with three colors
into the first 28 and 28 layers was 20
features then i would have to learn 48
million parameters clearly a number of
parameter status hardly doable so the
idea is to basically cut away weights
and that's done by first of all not
connecting every neuron to every neuron
but always only connecting neurons in a
certain neighborhood given by a radius
to connect to the following neurons so
have a pattern like this which greatly
reduces a number of links but
furthermore you assume that all the
links this link this and this link have
the same weights as the next triple of
links in this case so any links that you
can obtain by shifting left-right are
basically shared they are the same which
is to noted here so essentially you are
learning just three connections for the
entire layer here so three weights plus
one bias which is of course clearly much
less than 70 and that therefore you can
also imagine that the idea is that of
course now I have far fewer connections
and you can see that instead of having
40 some million I just have 1,500
connections in the first layer so that's
the benefit of convolutional networks
you just have much less to learn when
they use convolution and that works well
if you have multi-dimensional data set
that has strong local neighborhood
correlations of information is stored in
the local relation of pixel values or
values in general then if the machine
learning tasks needs a translational
invariance basically if you want to have
the network treat the left corner of
your image the same way as the right
corner or the middle part and last but
not least in order to reduce the number
of waves and biases in your system last
but not least I'd quickly like to point
out that this reduction in parameters
only holds for the spatial convolution
it does not hold for the combinations of
channels of input channels and output
channels for example you have 20 output
channels 3 input channels that basically
every channel coming in is connected via
convolution to every channel going out
so in this respect it's still fully
connected but with respect to the
spatial grid you have a convolution
all right then we have here element-wise
lair a ramp which is important in order
to introduce a nonlinear aspect in the
network because otherwise it would be
just a stack of linear transformations
resulting in an overall linear
transformation which would essentially
be just one layer so a real uu basically
puts in a nonlinear aspect and it looks
like this basically it's passes a
positive values just as there are and
blocks the negative values and this is a
non-linearity and basically if this
completes the idea of a neuron because a
neuron you assume that you collect
excitations from your neighborhood so
that's essentially what a linear layer
or convolution layer does and then if it
goes above a certain threshold it will
fire depending on how many excitations
receive and that is non-linearity here
and then that excitation is related by
the axon to the axon terminals so only
implementation of convolutional or
linear layers in combination with
nonlinear layers do you actually model a
neural network well riilu works
beautiful if the values come in around
zero if not you have an issue I'll get
back to that in a second and as I said
if you don't have them you just have a
linear layer so insert nonlinear layers
in between linear layers that's the
essence here real is a simplest new
nonlinear layer that we have in a system
but we of course have other ones like
the logistic sigmoid the hyperbolic
tangent and many more all right then
comes the pooling layer the pooling
layer is pretty much like a max filter
in image processing it just takes in a
certain region the maximum response and
then essentially down samples the grid
of neurons are so this is mostly used to
reduce the number of pixels that you
have if you have to cover a certain
spatial area and here basically this is
a pooling of two patches of
tends to with a stride of two so you
always move that patch by two neurons to
the side thereby down sampling the whole
image every time you go through a
pooling layer by a factor of two in
every dimension so a total of four so
the benefit is clear you'll reduce the
number of neurons needed the drawback is
okay in downsampled when you do this you
also destroy spatial information because
your resolution goes down that
information is lost on the other hand
you gain some invariance with respect to
translational movements so movements by
and it's a pixel forth and back don't
matter anymore the pooling layer would
take care of that and last but not least
any pooling layer is a non trainable
layer that means it doesn't have any
parameters that meet you meet 30
training it's just there and it just
works all right then
last but not least we have you some
simple layers the flat layer I don't
even mention or maybe the slide has been
just skipped they basically just
flattens the spatial topology of the
grid so I just have instead of a
multi-dimensional array just a vector at
the end so here at the end I have just
500 feature vector instead of neuron
sets though they make the the grid of
the image so that's basically takes our
determined dimensionality pretty much
like the the flattened command in
Mathematica then last but not least at
the end after having here two fully
connected layers that essentially work
as a classifier I have a soft max layer
that conveyor converts any kind of
activity of your neurons that can be
positive or negative into positive
numbers by basically applying the
exponential function and then
normalizing it over the sum of all the
values thereby get from essentially you
map values from the domain of real
numbers into the valve into the interval
0 & 1 and they then can be being no
can be interpreted as a distribution of
probabilities like it's the excitation a
certain of a certain muon it's I assume
that then that class for which that
neuron stands has a high probability in
the incoming it data so again sorry it
shouldn't say pulling lay it should say
soft max layer it doesn't have any
trainable parameters and it does map
from R to the interval 0 & 1 and that's
then essentially the last layer that you
need and the next thing would be to
train and to train you have to have a
loss layer so basically criteria that
tells you that you do good or not so
good and interestingly that it's not
explicitly given in Mathematica you
don't have to adhere to it or pay
attention to it because most cases
Mathematica can do refer the appropriate
loss layer for example if you have a
classification two classes and you end
up with a soft max layer then it's a
safe bet to assume that the last layer
is going to be a cross-entropy loss
layer which essentially measures the
difference between probabilities so the
probability distribution of a label
saying this is this in this class so
that would be the target that can be
provided as an index or just a
distribution like this and then of
course the distribution generated by the
neural network and it's say well if they
agree with each other essentially let's
say you have a high probability for the
last class and also index 3 then I
should start up here then this loss
layer will give you a small value if the
probabilities differ too much then you
get a high value and instead of having
an index it can also for the target have
a distribution down here that's the same
story essentially of course there are
other lost layers and depending what you
do you may want to have lost layers like
mean absolute loss or if you need square
loss and other ones ok
the
oops the next step would be to do the
training so this is my network and now
do real-time training on 1080 Nvidia
graphics card GPU train now those 650
cells and parameters by calling up next
train this is a network that I
constructed up there this is a site for
training data set I want to have all
information that I can get by a training
safe under result the validation set
which I explained in second is specified
here the number of trainings rounds that
I wanna in yeah run through is specified
here and this specifies if I run it on
CPU or GPU and clearly GPU is better
because it's faster and won't strain
your patient as much now what you see
here while it's training because
training does take time in this case
roughly 30 40 seconds you see the
progress of loss and error rate if you
have now the cross-entropy
loss layer you can calculate the loss
but furthermore since you classify in
two classes he can also measure the
accuracy error rate and they don't
really always have to combine their
subtle differences I don't go into now
but what you can see here is that you
have a blue line that goes up slightly
again and the orange line that goes down
the orange line is essentially the fit
of the training data basically how well
do i forecast examples from the training
data the validation data doesn't fit so
well you see it goes up again because
you have here in effect that's called
overfitting essentially what you do is
very much the same thing is if you fit a
polynomial to your data if the model
your polynomial is too flexible it will
start to fit not just the essence of the
data but also noise into it and as soon
as it starts to do that then it learns
some things that are probably not very
valuable to forecast yet unseen data and
the yet unseen data that's the
validation data
if that's not being well handled as
effectively as the training data I can
see that overfitting occurs and that's
clearly the case here
by the way this has taken total of 42
seconds I did digest 18,000 626 images
per second through the network doing
back back propagation and this is the
time evolution of the entropy and the
error rate and you can see the network
here is a confusion matrix isn't doing
great I mean accuracy of basically
getting 2/3 of the cases right it's
definitely not 1 something you expect
from a network so clearly this model
over fits and it's not doing great so
what do we do in order to get it working
better next slide I can do what I would
do with when I fit data I just get more
data because more data helps against
overfitting now quite often you don't
have more data so what you do is you
cheat a little bit but this is very
helpful cheating it's called data
augmentation and data augmentation
basically does the following you have to
consider what kind of transformations
are permissible to your data without
yeah changing its core meaning and if we
for example take this image of a plane
then I could very well trained also the
reflected horizontally reflected image
of a plane because it's very likely
there not just the plane from this angle
but also from this angle so this is a
perfectly valid data point furthermore
by doing this by basically applying
transformations that are in variances
with respect to the data type that I'm
looking at
I also ensure that the neural network
that I train exhibits that invariance
later on that it doesn't favor airplanes
flying from left to right over those
flying from right to left for example
what I can do a reflection sometimes you
can do rotations sometimes you can do
translational shifts
now just as an example this kind of
transformation you wouldn't want to do
if you were training digits because
reflecting or having a mirror image of a
digit it's definitely different than
having the original digits but
translation is okay and this can be
built into the network well first of all
you can generate this in mathematical
data yourself or even in the net encoder
you can have functions that generate
data on the fly or you could even do it
in the network by creating a layer
basically an image augmentation layer
that's the whole story here it basically
takes an image that's shifted around if
it's bigger than 32 times 32 and to make
it bigger active here padding layer and
I can specify other transformations like
the reflection probability and T I just
have a probability of having a
horizontal reflection because vertical
reflections would not be as permissible
because usually I don't see trucks or
cars or planes upside down all right so
basically on the fly I have here more
data than the 50,000 that I had
initially had and if I were not to train
this which I won't do because it takes
time losing a minute you will see that
the error rate of the accuracy has gone
up the error rate has gone further down
and just for comparison I did have to
learn it trained it a little bit longer
because it essentially had more data you
could see that it did do better you did
see that blue validation lines error
rate or the loss no this is error rate
goes down further than the other one
which was somewhat stuck at this level
around 30 percent all right so that's
the first trick next trick is a dropout
layer now dropout is pretty fancy idea
and the idea is instead of training one
network you could train several ones and
then basically I have them all vote on
an outcome and then the majority of
rules that idea of taking a whole
ensemble of machine learning classifiers
and then averaging over them is called
boosting and you can do the very same
with newer networks you would just
construct different neural networks and
then basically have them vote on the
result in order to make the whole thing
faster there is the idea
drop out layers essentially taken
network and randomly kill certain
neurons in a layer let's say 50% of the
ones in the hidden layer or certain
percentage whatsoever and thereby
randomly you generate all kinds of
networks and those you can't train all
at once in that train because robot
layer works while you're training and it
basically trains the ones to shared
weights
it doesn't retrain them it but it uses
them all but essentially you're training
a whole collection and whole ensemble of
neural networks by using dropout layer
and then once you apply that network you
don't do dropout anymore and then
essentially you do average over the
whole list of these trade networks and
essentially you get better results not
only that because you have fewer
parameters when you train this is a more
regularized more stable and less prone
to overfitting approach and because of
boosting you even get more accuracy so
that's what we did here we did even one
more other gadget we instead of having a
convolution layer that has a 5 x 5
kernel you can also just have a
concatenation of convolution set to 3 x
3 it must do the same thing this is
actually more efficient and will give
you better results because it's more
flexible even and well having both done
you can see that well you gain little
bit you see down here it is you can
train longer it stays stable longer and
thereby you get well I get roughly 2% on
average she can gain then the next thing
to consider is batch normalization we
had in our network and I pointed out
that already we have these
nonlinearities like the we Lou and the
reloj they can go astray in a way
because if the activity of the layer in
front of your real oh just when this
result is negative branch then you real
Oh will essentially just block all the
transmission
if it's just if you just have positive
values that are being conveyed then you
don't have any non-linearity so
essentially you should make sure that
the activity of your network should
average around the zero point here and
that's where batch normalization comes
in because here I just basically took
the beginning of the trade network that
we just did put the took the front part
off the network we can just see what I
did here hold on I basically took the
first few layers until I was approaching
at this ramp in seven and I was just
looking like what is a probability
distribution of the values that go
through this non-linearity and therefore
I extracted the first part of the
network I ran generated whole batch of
images random through the network here
recorded the activities and then plotted
the activities as a histogram and you
see well they are shifted and so it is
beneficial to put what's called a batch
normalization layer in front of such a
real ooh and if you do that let's see we
gained another few percentage points so
let it help alright so what else is
there well now comes the obvious if you
want to better have better results you
just basically take a better or bigger
network and the first there two ways to
make a network bigger you can just make
it wider essentially saying instead of
let's say dealing with I don't know what
I did use initially 30 or so features I
can create oh I think I think I used 20
features only instead of using 20
features I can work with 60 features
having more features I can learn more I
have more information and that in
general should work better drawback of
course is you have more parameters to
learn so it gets a little bit more
tedious but basically just increasing
the number of channels can give you
quite a boost going up here now to an
error rate of just 14% or up to 86 87
and here you can clearly see this was a
previous learning curve and now we are
definitely almost four or five percent
under that so that's one way to go and
next we can see I'm doing time little
running late here then I can go for more
depth just having not just the three
layers but having four layer packages
and essentially same story can you
ignore get even under ten percent error
rate and so forth I think you get the
idea how you can improve a data set a
new network step by step to accommodate
the breadth of the the of the problem
now quite off more and basically it's
the first question I get asked when I
talk about newer networks it's like yes
it's all great but there are so many
different your networks out there how
can I make sense of that well first of
all let me go up here we do have I'm
just switching to a browser I'm sorry my
front-end is slow because I'm
broadcasting well essentially what I'm a
child always quickly describe what I'm
hope to see in a second here I we have a
network repository where we collect all
the well-established
well-functioning and pre trained in most
cases networks that have been published
in the literature and instead of having
to train a network yourself you can
basically upload this neural net and
then take it from there
and don't have to train it yourself so
that that way you cannot just quickly
train no networks of it say if you III
oh yeah here we go okay so that's the
which basically shows that you have here
not just the convolution Network but a
whole module of convolutions and the
reasoning behind this is fairly
straightforward I
tall or you mentioned that the
convolution Network basically takes all
the input channels and combines them
with all the output channels so you have
number of input channels times number of
output channels and for each of these
you have to do a convolution now in
order to cut that down that workload and
to make it more efficient the inception
modules basically segment the number of
channels into sub segments and only in
those sub segments they do convolutional
layers of convolutions and here in one
segment they do five times five
convolutions two in a row then here
basically just pooling you have three
times three convolutions and here I just
have essentially an identity map and all
of these then basically combined at the
output so I avoid having to combine
every channel with every channel and I
even have now the benefit of being able
to do shortcuts or to have a different
kind of convolutions was different with
so that's the benefit of Inception that
worked really well then well worked
fairly well in the sense that you had an
increase in flexibility without the
increase in learnable parameters to that
extent and then another issue is that if
you increase a number of layers then
what's problem is is that the learning
gradient methods the back propagation
doesn't work anymore because usually
either the gradient that you need to
learn explodes gets too big or too small
and then after a certain number of
layers you're learning basically stops
and also to avoid that the net graph or
the module that they have implemented
here is a trick it's called well it's a
residual trick the idea is basically if
I implement a new layer
first of all I implement identity map
essentially well identity identity map
with a real ooh where don't do anything
really to the data but in order to learn
I have here network that trains
deviation from
identity so I can plug this in this
layer would work right away but then it
would start to modify and learn more and
this identity mapping here makes sure
that the the grade it doesn't decay as
fast so these are some of the
considerations in in network design and
now assuming we have a great work
network working we can play with it and
we can analyze what's doable what's not
doable and for example here I have an
image of a book and the question what I
basically says tells me now okay
I did find a book in this so it did look
down here this is a somewhat tricky case
I have the other case I said I can
quickly call up here for example I can
visualize where the clues are that
Network used in order to trend earth to
predict that this is an Alaskan Malamute
this is done very simply I basically
calculate the output the probability of
this specific class by covering up
iteratively areas of this network of
this image and just seeing how the
problems use goes up and down tells me
if I have covered up an essential
feature or not and that's in here
that's back of the notebook as a network
sensitivity map a command that you can
then use and it's pretty interesting you
can for example you see that this is
classified as a Morgan horse by just
looking at the shoulder and say ears
seem to be decisive or if you look here
at the wolf the gray wolf the snout is
apparently a big deal and now I have a
porcelain version of AB wolf and this
goes way bad it misclassifies but
knowing what it looks at you can see
what goes wrong just looked at the stand
down there and classified it as a soap
dish so it gives you some insight of
what's going on then we can also fool
these things you probably have heard
that these neural networks don't really
grasp the content of the image as humans
do and we'll demonstrate this with a
trick where I call this how to
crow Tiger essentially I have here the
inception Network I have a cockroach and
I have a tiger image and network can
classify both of them very diligently so
yeah cockroach and tiger works perfect
but what I can do is I can build a
network where the lowest layer is the
tiger and then I basically do propagate
back propagation and learn that bottom
layer which is the image to actually
give me the output cockroach and you
will see that and we need very few
alterations to the original image to
fool the network because the features
that are picked up by the first layer
are very strongly high frequency layers
high frequency clues that the human eye
doesn't really pick up and therefore at
the end of the day what I have trained
hold on so here I trained the whole
thing you see suddenly kaboom it thinks
it's a cockroach and now I create a new
tiger and this is my tiger but this is
not the tiger that you have seen before
it's slightly different you can hardly
see it it's basically invisible to the
eye the human eye but for the network
it's now a cockroach because I have
changed some high-frequency features
that are picked up by the first
convolutional network that completely
misguides the entire process here and
it's even pretty certain that the
cockroach it's not 9 percent certain and
what's the difference between the images
of the tiger and this cockroach tiger
well you see some well almost noise like
high frequency stuff and last but not
least I'd like to point out that this is
an of course Network specific because if
I come up with another newer network
like image identify this would still
work which still identify this as a
tiger alright I think I'm running out of
time just bear with me one more one more
example quickly uh which is pretty cool
as to how to visualize the internals of
a network because it helps to know what
these
neurons especially the hidden neurons
learn as they are trained on a data set
now what's really easy to extract is at
the bottom level which is here just
extracting the kernels of the first
convolution layer and you can see that
it picks up here edges between
complementary colors lines somewhat like
gaba wavelets so this is somewhat
typical for any kind of vision task and
it's interesting to see that no matter
what you train the first layers always
look pretty much the same interesting
the other thing is and that's why that
there's a difference between human
vision and machine vision this is just
basically picking up at the highest
resolution of the image whereas the
human brain or human vision says visual
system basically tries to process image
at all scales at all resolutions that's
why it's not tricked so easily
all right then there's another way and
essentially this is now deep dream on a
patch of neurons in the network so
instead of just trying to activate or
hype up a whole layer in the network I
can also just go ahead and specify just
a part of a layer which I do here by the
way and I just definitely defined this
as a mouse function if I saying I'd like
to activate just these neurons in this
part of the neuron and running them the
dream algorithm i essentially dream up
the features that these neurons what
essentially yeah we act on that they
have learned and for example if I look
now at the eighth channel of the posit
layer for D then I see that I get to see
these features and here just for
comparison these are other neurons that
you see that they pick up completely
different patterns this is a pattern
that looks like a fox face this is a
pattern that looks more like yeah it's a
reptile or turtles it looks like a
feather fluffy thing so one can see how
more complex the features get as you go
along and
I think I'll leave it as that this is
just a quick example that you can also
find in other presentations it is the
idea of basically taking the network
stripping the last classifying layers
and then just use the intermediate
vector or a feature vector as some
feature function on which you can then
do a nearest neighbor classification and
that helps you then to retrieve images
that are very much alike so we can
quickly run this just for the heck of it
I have here oops for that to activate
them network well I'm not gonna run it
basically I have here a network that I
extract it just a top part and if I
apply this on an image I get a vector
which I just
unfortunately delete it and then if I
have a whole data set like this here
then I can run a nurse or train newest
function on that feature vector and
thereby I can calculate a nearest dog
function that basically takes an image
in calculates a feature vector finds the
nearest feature vector and then looks up
in the data set what image does it
belong to and that helps you to come up
with commands like nearest dog he just
put one dog like here for that the way
the breed right now I'm sorry and he
gets the same breed she were or doodle
it's all no problem okay so I haven't
gone through this most tedious part now
you are in for a joy ride with my
colleague Giulio please take over thank
you and by the way the Q&A session is
going to be afterwards
you
hey Julia just so you know you are muted
hello can you hear me I hope so so great
that's better let me go fullscreen and
so thanks Marcus he took all their hard
work on himself so I can basically start
from what he built and what Sebastian
bill last week sorry weeks ago to show
you some real world models that have
been converted to work in our framework
and that you can do yourself to train
yourself if you want
so a quick a quick outline of them what
I'm gonna talk about today the first
like let's move beyond simple
classification we've been seeing stand a
classification now in every possible way
I want to show a bit more what you can
do with the standard feature extraction
pipeline on an image and how you can use
those features to predict or that they
infer compute a great number of
different features we are going to look
at first video feature to feature
conversion some landmark regression for
facial key points then I want to look at
the pixel level processing one would be
image Claude ization and the other one
would be pixel level segmentation and
sorry and the final task I want to look
at is object detection that is kind of a
combination of regression for bounding
boxes and standard image classification
for the classification of the object
within the bounding box so I want to
start with a simple model which is
landmark regression this model is
basically a standard feature extraction
pipeline with a convolutional network
and on top of this you have classifier
that is not predicting a claw clasp so
these are predicting and probability
distribution but is directly predicting
Numerical features on the image so let's
have a look at how this can be done in
the warm language so the this is the
model I'm using this is the vanilla CNN
for facial and my regression is
available in that model and if we look
at the first part we feature a
structural part we can see that this is
basically convolutional network very
similar to what Marcus showed you before
so we have a bunch of convolutional
layers in this case we have four we have
an activation with an absolute
hyperbolic tangent and max pooling layer
to down sample the feature Maps after
these this bit this part can be like
labeled feature extractor after after
this part has done its job then we use a
very very small classification network
you can see this red layers here are the
fully connected the linear layers that
are predicting the features and these
layers are basically used to convert the
features visual maps into the abyss
flattened layer that flattens the
features Maps into a big factor and then
we we compute the regression features on
tones and on this big backdrop okay
first thing this is a this model as a
specific requirement and this model
requires data to be standardized and the
way we can handle this
within the framework is using some
parameter extra parameters in that in
the sorry in the net encoder but I don't
think I've been showing so far so I
wanted to quickly check on these net
encoder supports a mean image that can
be a number I like a color or can be a
full-fledged image that will be
subtracted from your data set and a
variance image which can be used to
standardize like bring the data to one
variance B before you send the batch to
the to the network so we can have a
better look at what we are using here
like the the mean image is probably what
you expect and the variance image
captures the
you
hello hello
can you hear me now okay sorry my
headset had a glitch I was trying to
figure it out so what we what we have
here is as I was saying like standard
normalization for the data set
once this kicks in we can send the data
to the network and given that these
metal predicts absolute coordinates in
the 0-1 range we want to define
something that we have also not seen yet
is a quick post processing step that
will take the output of a network in the
0-1 range and rescale using the image
dimension of a image and I'm gonna use
many evaluation networks in this talk
I'm not gonna explain all of them
because they can get quite complicated
they just want to say that like it's
very easy given that like this frame of
his building in the language to use all
kind of image processing functions that
are already available in the language so
in this case is pretty simple I just
create this evaluation function and then
what I do is I run it on the network and
I see that I get five scale points and
if I I light them on the image I see
that what I just did is to detect them
two eyes the nose and the boundary or
the mouth so this is kind of a not too
many features we have also more
complicated networks which can detect up
to 20 features in like landmarks on the
on the image but I just wanted to start
small and show what simple addition to a
convolutional architecture can do and
this is fully trainable in the in the
framework it's also very fast to train
another example that I I want to show
after these is a slightly more
complicated or emits a way more
complicated but actually for now we are
going to look at the inside this
architecture and we can see that there
are not so many new concept compared to
what you've seen already so this is an
image colorization Network I think it's
called color net and I picked this
because the authors are doing something
very interesting here so they have a
standard
feed restructure pipeline which is these
like purplish layers here and these
layers are extracting low-level features
on the image and then these features are
sent to two different tasks they are
sent to mid-level features and then to a
claw ization network that is up sampling
and converting those features to colors
but they are also sent to a global
classification network and why this
because this way we can basically have a
built-in prior generator for the image
within the network
so these colorization tasks will not be
just dependent on the pixel content per
se but we also have the advantage of the
prior knowledge from the classification
Network but for example we'll say that
this is a night scene or autumn scene or
indoor scene so like the color palette
may be affected by this let's have a
look at how this can be done so first
thing we need to know a little bit of
color science and lucky for you and me I
have this happen to be my expertise so
if we check this conversation problem in
if you look at it in in a more general
term what we see is that we have we have
a 3d distribution of RGB colors and we
want to go here from just a one-day
distribution of luminal levels but
working this RGB space is quite
complicated because we see that this is
a intrinsically 3d problem and we can
greatly simplify this this problem by
using some color science knowledge and
convert this image to a luminance
chrominance face like a lady and labial
lab it's it's a space where luminance is
decoupled from the color component so
you see that this would be the luminance
pretty close to the grayscale balance in
the image and the two color components
are basically the distance from the
center here so I just have a line in the
center which is decoupled from the
colors and I want to predict the the
lateral translation with my network
so how does we start first I have to
create a standard feature structure
network this is very very simple very
shallow I have one two three four five
six convolution layer to extract the
features and standard ramp for
activation this these features would be
sure these are the low-level features
that will be shared by am the so between
between the mid-level features and the
global features for the total global
prior one small difference here that we
are not used
but we are we are using the here is the
stride parameter in the convolution
layer that basically makes the kernel
jump from one pixel instead of one for
month except to the next from one pixel
to the one after the next and this
effectively increases the special range
the special range of the convolution
layer and makes makes it so what we
don't need the de max pooling layer
anymore in this type of model the mid
level features are just a standard fixed
size convolutional network one thing to
notice is that in this model we are
compressing not in the special domain
but in the channel domain so basically
all the information that comes to this
500 club channels is compressed to 256
so this enforces an informational
compression and this stills the
information then we have the global
feature which is a slightly smaller
convolutional network followed by some
standard classification done by a linear
layer and when we put all together we
can use all this with the correlation
network that takes all the features and
up samples them and use more convolution
to go from features to the chromium
values so okay all this to say we have
the Croatian Network let's try and use
it so we get a nice dog actually let's
look at the dog
before I convert it to grayscale and
what I hope is to recover this color
information so I create here another
small evaluation function that is adding
the luminance back and putting the
channels also go there so what we see
here is that we miss some kind small low
level details like the eyes were like
browner here like kind of duller but
overall it got correctly the shade of
fur and the background and we can even
check using our image processing
functions the distance between the
original and in the recolored image and
we see indeed that the eyes were not
really correctly but most of all the
background and dog fur is fine and
we have a median error of 1% across the
image why did I waste a little time
illustrating the natural structure
because first I think is interesting to
see how we can put things together and
also real world models together and then
because it's very easy in the Wolfram
language to use them and do surgery
operation then and alter them without
having to retrain without having to do
any look and of low-level operation so I
show that we have a global prior plus
local features but there's nothing that
forces us to take them from the same
image so here for example I'm using a
some surgery function to split the
network in different parts and send the
original image in input to the mid like
low to mid level conversation part and
the low to global level and global prior
part is taken from a different image so
here for example I use a different dog
this is a dog on a blueish background
this behind the C and now I want to see
if I can use some of the color platform
this image predicting to predict the
color of the different image and we see
here that basically the the grass now is
not picked correctly as grass because
I'm forcing the network to use different
priors and this get this bluish tint all
this kind of thing is a sandy I've seen
many images in the training set they
have kind of a sandy beach and then see
behind so is going for something like
that let's move to another task we've
seen classification let's let's turn it
up to 11 and instead of building one
classifier for the whole image we build
one classifier for each pixel this is
basically what semantic segmentation is
doing what we are doing here is using
the standard convolutional pipeline to
create features again but then we want
to use those features on a much bigger
feature map that will be converted in
many many many sorry class distributions
to in order to do these tasks I am using
a specific specific model but highlights
interesting features but you should pay
attention to when you train these very
deep networks we've seen across in
literature and over the years that
deeper model are usually better but
there's a limit to that like at first
people started adding layers to end
greater and greater accuracy and but
after after a while people realize that
there was a diminishing return and this
was for a variety of reasons first
adding more layers add the extra memory
and training cost which is not a limit
to the model per se but it's a middle to
how fast you can test and train new
models then you have intrinsic issues
with this because the features map get
increasingly small the deeper your
network and and if you don't make been
smaller then again you you run into
memory and train time cost because then
that was become very very very big
then as the diminishing return in
accuracy so them is you don't get linear
improvement by adding more layers so the
last improvements on on image net that
were done with following this let's add
more layer approach so like a few
percent improvement doubling the amount
of layer and which is something that you
cannot do to infinity and then you have
a problem which is a problem of
vanishing gradients at Marcos briefly
touch on before and actually this the
resin architecture was introduced
exactly for this for this reason you
want to to limit this vanishing gradient
issue or also the inception they follow
basically two different approaches one
combines feature by concatenation while
the rest that combines the features by
submission still if we look at this and
this plot that is taken from this paper
wider or deeper and what the authors
actually are wondering like how to
improve on the standard Resnick model
and this is the key point we see that
the gradient is still vanishing for very
very big networks that means which we
are not truly training this network
end-to-end because certain layers
actually freeze during the training as
soon as the corresponding gradient is
zero so that this tells us but is not is
not an exact science to pick the right
architecture and there's no clear way
it's not that deeper is always the
better or why there is always the better
and the model I pick here tries to
strike a balance between
depth and width
and this is a pretty shallow for a deep
neural net this has just 17 residual
units all those resinates but this was
guaranteed to Train end to end so when
we propagate the gradient back or this
the changes affects all these blocks and
once we extract the features with this
type of residual Network then we use we
have to compare them to the to the set
of probability distributions so what we
what we do is we use this transpose
layer you see at the end of the network
you have 21 channels but correspond to a
21 classes that I'm try to classify and
the feature map is 63 by 63 so what I
want here is to to convert these 21
channels in the 21 probability value for
the classes in the pixel so in the end
the end result is a probability
distribution net that I will trash hole
to get the segmentation out so let's see
let's use this test image of the cat and
the dog at this a slightly bigger
evaluation function because I have to
probably rescale and threshold all these
property distribution this will be
probably in the notebook I compute the
segmentation this takes a little while
and once is done let's run this right
away okay here I I see that I classified
like three different regions that are
this mysterious one nine and thirteen
let's see what they correspond specially
okay they seem pretty much overlapping
with the objects in my in my image this
is slightly doggish pixel here I don't
know why they never got confused but
overall we are quite fine I would say
and here let's see if this correspond to
the right class is yes the black is
background ready sketch and this green
is dog so we did a good job let's see
how much time do I have here oh yes yes
s have a lot of time so after these my
final model for today
we'll be kind of let's combine together
all the things I've learned to build a
kind of a higher task network but has to
combine both object the object detection
and the classification so what do you
what are the ingredients that you need
to build a proper object detection
functions I mean you need at least to do
two things you need to predict where in
objects are like if an image contains
objects where they are and the exact
bounding box of the object because you
want to know
where an object begins and ends
but this would be pretty trivial usually
we also want to know what the object is
so we need to embed also a third class
which is a standard image classification
but this time on the bounding box the
model I pick to illustrate this is the
yellow network here it is your honor
stands for you only look once and the
idea is that with a quick look at the
image you are able to infer a great load
of information so how this network is
structure this is again a quite short
convolution network but makes use of
something that I'm just mentioning here
but because a great deal about that
which is a skipped connection or
shortcut correction and the idea is that
you may want to address your models to
have features at different scale talk to
each other so you may want to connect
like more low level features at the
beginning like local to some of course
the features at the end and this way you
don't have a result that is directly
depending only on the course features
but you can also directly see the local
features and this is what this model is
doing once once the features have been
computed those are sent to the yep here
it is the final module which is doing
the three things I mentioned before so
we want to take those features Maps and
convert them to coordinates for the
bounding boxes the probability for the
object to be in the bounding box or not
and the condition probability of the
objects pertaining to a given class so
let's say I have 80% probability of
having an object here and this object
has also 60% of ability of being a cat
or a dog in the image for example
there's a cupboard here you may know
already that neural networks are not I
mean they need to be trained they'll get
they are trained by greatness and so
they need to be pushed around and if I
want to predict absolute big numbers
it's it's very difficult to have them
converge correctly and quickly so you
have your tricks like risk aiding
coordinates from 0 to 1 in the land mass
defection or using a hyperbolic tangent
to keep the span of the output of layer
constrained but in this case we really
want to use different coordinates in the
image so there are several tricks that I
use in the object detection networks
that are worth mentioning first one is
let's not predict the absolute position
but let's start from set of priors on a
grid and we ask the network to predict
the offset or were shipped in the
vertical or horizontal position from the
grid cells and then we can do the same
for the for the with an N height of the
network and we don't pretend erectus we
pre computed set of anchor boxes that
have a given size or experts ratio and
what we predict are the scale factor but
would multiply the width and the height
so this way the you see we are providing
this constant array that contains the
hour prior to the network and you can
even pre compute the priors on your data
set Orem or an effective data stuff real
images to make that more meaningful and
then you can this way you can greatly
simplify the job that Elektra has to do
and if this will help the converters a
lot so once we have this OB ingredient
in place we can see what happens with
the with the natural result so in this
specific implementation of Yolo we have
a grid which is 13 by 13 and we have
also provided the 5 size priors for the
bounding boxes so
in total the network will generate 845
prediction and these are is basically
with a fixed number so the network we
generate always this amount of
prediction and try to be to make them
all good predictions so in the end we
mean we have three results the box is
the conditional probability and the
object Ness factor for the four bounding
box let's have a quick look inside and
see what these boxes correspond to oh
here it is trying to render a lot of
rectangles so here are all the
rectangles that have been predicted by
the network and I scaled them by the
option s value so the more probable an
object is removable the box contains an
object they have oblivia sorry the high
probability of a box containing object
the thicker the rectangle is and this is
like for old type of objects but then we
we have condition probabilities so we
can we can check for example at what is
the conditional probability of having a
catch in the box and if you remember the
original image we see the cat was on
this side so like all the boxes here now
are the one with the highest probability
and all the other ways suppressed or we
can check for the dog and again here we
have different a different set of boxes
that have been highlighted so let's
let's move down to see how this performs
on the on the real image okay this gives
me two rectangles which is exactly what
I expect this final value is doesn't
look too high but you have to consider
that this is the conditional probability
so it's been pre multiplied and if we
highlight this on the image we see that
indeed we got quite good correspondence
between where the cat and the dog are in
the image
and here I rush this a bit so I'm close
to the end of my talk I just have one
final example that it's live so you get
to look at me and this will hopefully
work and give him that is that or is
pretty fast hi this is me and given that
the talk is almost over I will soon
celebrate with the glass is exactly a
wine glass and I will pour a bottle this
to show that you can also build real
time application and of course now I
don't have to I don't have time to show
this in in great detail but you can you
can for example take an application like
this and deploy it on the I'm staying
here and deploy it on the web
with cloud deploy and you can have all
kind of ogner Network application served
to your colleagues or your customers or
like all kind of different people so
thanks for paying attention to me and I
guess I'm staying here too at the end
because this full screen oh yeah here it
is so I use this to say goodbye and we
are going to have a Q&A section session
very soon so stay tuned and again thanks
for your attention
all right Marcus if you wanted to share
first and mic up and answer some
questions you are free to do so
mute hello everyone so I see we made it
without losing too many attendees that's
great thanks for sticking with us we
were both busy trying to answer
questions and I think most of the
questions got answered then maybe a few
big topics one topic that I'd like to
try to answer is what about outer
encoders are a topic that I would have
loved to include but time is a
limitation factor today so I didn't put
in the original talk but maybe I can get
an example of an outer encoder right now
and here and another topic which I'd
like to then defer to Julia because he's
the expert and that one is our
integration with the Amazon AWS
integration so if you don't have a GPU
at home and cannot do demanding
calculations training tasks there's
still an option that you have in the
cloud all right let me try to find my
outer encoder example that could take
maybe hopefully not too long
oh yeah okay got one so this is an
example it goes back to the the Lynette
Network and the M this data set so what
I'm loading here hopefully this will
work out of the box that is it is right
now this is an idea of learning about
digits of handwritten digits without
utilizing the labels and okay so what I
will do here is I'll just load again the
resource for M missed the training date
of the test data and then what I'm doing
now is I want to do a classifier Network
but I have here what's called a simple
or outer encoder network the idea is
very straightforward
assuming you have images but you don't
have labels for them what could you
compare the image with of course with
itself and for that matter in order for
the network to learn something you have
something like a in code and network
somewhat similar to classify a network
that we discussed an hour ago so
essentially a convolutional networks
Rams and so forth that take image data
and then try to compress it so there's a
bottleneck in the middle so you
basically will try to compress the
amount of information in an image to a
few channels well maybe a few hundred
channels maybe a handful of channels
depends what the image is like and then
since you cannot learn the these
networks here the activity of these
neurons you can have a generative
network again so that's a generation
part it basically deconvolve there also
deconvolution layers one may be inverse
convolution layers it should be called
or transposed convolution layers it's
not deconvolution strictly speaking
anyway layers that somewhat do the
opposite as convolution they expand the
data again and the idea is here too
generate the image so that what came in
looks very much like what comes out here
so network that would satisfy this is
this particular one it's an auto encoder
with encoding a network that has a
convolutional layer a ram convolution
layer at ramp and so forth and then a
deconvolution layer in the decoder
pretty much mirror mirror wise and last
but not least I have also a loss layer
here cross-entropy layer that then
compares the input with the output so
the entire network is down here and it
looks like this it will essentially take
input at the end of the day it will be
noisy input that's whole idea of this
network of handwritten digits and then
it should try to decode it and the
output should be the clean image of the
the image that we have so essentially we
take the handwritten images we add noise
feed the noisy image into the encoder
and decoder and hopefully we have
generated here image D most image of the
incoming digit and that's being compared
with the original digits and that is
here done by a cross-entropy so that is
then okay this is I think an older
version a that I build this on so I'm
not sure if this is going to work or not
and I use everything okay okay
I won't evaluate achieve this may take
time anyway but I will just call this up
so this is a trained version now of the
encoder and that I can then run on a
noisy image and see what it does so I
just extract the encoder part put in a
digit and we construct it and I get
basically the same thing out so that's
already promising and I can run this now
on noisy images and run this through the
constructor here and obtain clean
version of the noisy input now this
works exceptionally well because the
prior here is that you have numbers and
if you have if you can basically train
the network on that prior then the
obstruction of the noise can be quite
substantial and pretty much like a human
being you will be able to pick up still
the number that's being hidden by the
noise pretty much like a human being
because you know it's a number you know
what kind of numbers they are what
shapes they have or that is in the
network and therefore that network and
process that noise better than any any
ordinary noise reduction filter that
would not have this prior knowledge
about handwritten digits and here's just
another plot of comparing it so yep that
conclude concludes a little excursion
into auto-encoders I don't unfortunately
don't have an example of more
extravagant out in quarters right now
working like a variational out in coder
or even disentangled auto-encoder that's
the latest development but that example
I still have to build all right over to
you Julia are you ready
hello yep
do we still have time to go on with the
Christian answer oh I didn't know how we
we well but yeah we can do a few more
minutes of Q&A before we wrap up if
you've got some some questions you'd
like to answer just anything else you
want to show before we close up that's
fine okay so Jarek thing okay thinks I
was showing to people in the in the
question panel so people ask me about a
lot of questions about retraining and so
actually could you increase your
notebook to 125 please and so people ask
me about retraining let's let's see
there are basically two two ways to to
train a network internet model is on a
train that are done automatically so
when you have a natural like this with
uninitialized layers that means this
convolution layer they don't really have
anything in the weights and biases and
also the linear layer they are
completely empty in this case net rain
will automatically call something called
net initialize and this will create oh
yeah this business model has no input so
let me show you with a convolution layer
convolution there let's say we have like
five channels three by three convolution
this of course will will fail because
the convolution layer is completely a
symbolic object so I don't really know
how big is the thing coming in and if I
want to put numbers in here I need to
know how biggest is the input expect it
to be so I can do input for example this
is going to be a tree channel 100 by 100
image and then now these layers contain
actual numbers so this is what net rain
will do on an uninitialized network but
there is no reason to do this if you
already have a network so if I get
another net model
and I get the standard Lynette which is
trained then these layers they do
contain numbers and if I call my train
on this I will start from this is
extract stages yeah in the training so
that you don't lose any of the
information that was here any actor
because you can use these you can stop
the training at any point or take any
Metro that you've generating with our
checkpointing system and restart my
training from there so you don't lose
any information there one thing you may
want to do is you may want to let's say
that you have like three training
certain layers all of them on some tasks
and I just want to retrain the final
classifier for example another task so I
do I want to fix the weights and biases
of the convolution layer and I can do
this by a learning rate multipliers so
learn Ray multipliers will allow me to
say to settle basic ideas as yeah a
multiplier factor for the the update
stack for for each layer and if I set
this to zero the layer won't be touched
so this is an effective way to do fine
tuning on the network and let's say this
was one of the main things that was
asked let's see there were another
another question that I got it was
interesting but I cannot find it anymore
so I guess there are not any more
questions in the in the box I will just
call it today and we can finish here all
right well thank you so much Julie oh
and thank you Marcus that is going to
that will conclude our presentations for
today we hope you enjoyed learning about
image processing with deep neural nets
an email will be sent to everyone in
today's audience with a link to the
webinar recording and the download links
for the presentation notebooks remember
that you can obtain a free trial of
Mathematica from Wolfram calm and try
all these examples for your
we look forward to seeing you online
again May 30th for the third and final
webinar in this series when our topic
will be deep learning for audio analysis
and natural language processing as
always you'll receive an a reminder
email about this session I wanted to
remind everyone that we also are running
a data science webinar series kind of in
tandem with this machine learning and
that continues one week from today I
have the link on the screen right now
and that will also be shared in the chat
as you exit today's webinar survey will
appear and please fill this out as we
use the survey results to guide us in
making important decisions in the wool
firm technology stack and adding the
features that are most important to our
user community thank you advance for
your feedback we will see you next time
and have a great day